bonjour alexis heureuse de trouver dans
cette matinale d'air france alors encore
un week-end difficile pour la candidate
du parti socialiste anne hidalgo au plus
bas dans les sondages
oui alors anne hidalgo déjà dans les
sondages certains sondages la m derrière
le candidat communiste fabien roussel à
2% alors que roussel sera 3% là bien du
mal à atteindre les 5% et elle avait un
meeting qui devait relancer une énième
fois sa campagne à aubervilliers cette
fois ci et
la salle était quasiment vide les images
sont sans appel alors là les caméras du
parti socialiste on zoome et sur le
public qui était là au premier rang elle
a eu du change et son entrée pour éviter
de montrer combien la salle était vide
et on voit bien que la dynamique
n'existe pas derrière cette candidature
dany d'algos même le parti socialiste a
du mal à faire campagne avec cette
question de la primaire populaire
faut-il y aller ne faut-il pas y aller
pour anne hidalgo c'est non elle veut
aller jusqu'au bout comme elle l'a redit
ce week end mais jusqu'au bout de quoi
c'est la question que se posent les
militants socialistes mais aussi les
électeurs en faisant une telle campagne
peut-elle aller jusqu'au mois d'avril si
toutes les salles continue d'être à ce
point peu remplie et si les sondages
continuent d'être assez bas ça risque
d'être compliqué pour la candidate qui
peine à faire valoir son programme ses
idées et qui à gauche et bien souffrent
bien sûr de l'image du parti socialiste
mais aussi de son image à paris et du
manque finalement d'entrain ou du manque
peut-être de mobilisation des militants
du parti socialiste sur le terrain il ya
aussi cette histoire de vote populaire
la primaire populaire plus de 300 mille
inscrits à cette primaire populaire est
ce que c'est la dernière chance d'une
candidature possible d'union de la
gauche alors la primaire populace et
plus de 460 mille inscrits 1 hier soir
selon les organisateurs de cette
primaire populaire donc un beau succès
d'inscription de gens qui veulent voter
pour un candidat d'union de la gauche
c'est ce qui est promis par cette
primaire populaire
le problème c'est que ni anne hidalgo ni
yannick jadot pour
europe ecologie les verts ni jean-luc
mélenchon pour l'union populaire nous
souhaitent que leurs noms apparaissent
dans le scrutin de cette primaire
populaire disant que c'est une manoeuvre
qui ne sert finalement à rien si ce
n'est à pousser la candidature de
christine pour lui gras qui est la seule
à appeler de ses voeux cette primaire
populaire qui a dit que c'était un beau
moment de démocratie participative et
c'est vrai que s'il ne reste que
christiane taubira charlotte
marchandises et pierre larrouturou et
une autre candidate évidemment la plus
connue c'est christiane taubira donc on
a l'impression que toute cette primaire
populaire est en train de s'effondrer
malgré les quatre cent mille personnes
inscrits puisque il n'y aurait de choix
entre quatre candidats dont trois très
peu connu et christiane taubira donc il
est là un vrai problème et puis encore
une fois ce n'est pas un scrutin en
ligne avec des règles qui ont changé
avec un pacte également de la primaire
populaire qui fait que le gagnant devra
intégrer dans son équipe de campagne les
perdants on voit mal jean luc mélenchon
prendre derrière lui anne hidalgo ou
yannick jadot ou même christiane taubira
il a décidé de rompre avec le parti
socialiste il ya très longtemps donc on
voit bien que derrière c'est un peu une
primaire des perdants ou quelque chose
ou on sait que ce candidat issu des
urnes de la primaire n'ira de toute
façon pas forcément au second tour est
quelque chose d'assez tragique dans la
façon dont tout ça est organisé le même
si quatre cent mille personnes inscrits
évidemment c'est important il y a des
gens qui attendent d'un candidature de
christiane taubira qui a peu pourrait
peut-être pour certains changer la donne
à gauche mais à quelques mois du scrutin
on est maintenant fin janvier le scrutin
ait lieu en avril sans programme sans
parti ça semble un pari risqué et c'est
bien ce que se disent de nombreux
électeurs de gauche et concrètement est
ce que la gauche peut-elle encore avoir
sa place au second tour alexis compte
tenu de la dynamique de la campagne bas
et c'est toute la question évidemment
quand on voit que cumuler le camp de
gauche fait péniblement 25% on peut se
demander si le second tour est
atteignable avec autant de candidats de
gauche parce que même dans cette
primaire populaire vous n'avez pas du
tout philippe poutou un as kazim les
candidates dit d'extrême gauche qui ne
sont pas du tout considérés et dans les
candidats de gauche
il y a que jean luc mélenchon qui arrive
à flirter avec les 10 % d'intentions de
vote tous les autres sont autour de 5
yannick jadot parfois à 7 mais
globalement on voit bien que la
dynamique à gauche et aussi la difficile
à faire exister tandis qu'à droite alors
qu'il ya plusieurs candidats eric
zemmour valérie pécresse même emmanuel
macron non encore candidat mais qui va
arriver marine le pen eh bien ils ont
tous au delà des 10 12 14 % donc il ya
un vrai problème de visibilité est aussi
de rendre ces programmes de gauche
audible et c'est je pense pas que cette
primaire va aider quoi que ce soit
d'ailleurs alex miel le pass vaccinale 1
qui entre en vigueur ce matin et cette
information qui aurait pas eu une grande
importance sauf que c'est le jour de
l'entrée en vigueur du du pass vaccinale
marlène schiappa état isolement est là
elle a attrapé coville est une de plus
depuis hier oui marlène schiappa est à
l' isolement elle devait débattre hier
avec fabien roussel annulé mais elle
fait elle sur ses ailes et on remplit
ses fonctions à distance et excusez moi
et on voit bien que c'est encore un
membre du gouvernement vacciner sans
doute qu'ils attrapent le coc vide et se
passe vaccinale qui arrive alors même
que le ms dit que l'épidémie est en
train de se résorber en europe puisque
60% des européens vont attraper au
micron qui est sans danger pour la
plupart des gens qui vont l'attraper on
voit bien qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne
va pas avec ce pass vaccinale qui arrive
à contre courant alors que angleterre
espagne irlande arrête avec les mesures
coercitives emmanuel macron lui s'entête
dans des mesures qui emmerdent les
français et qui risque de lui coûter
cher pour l'élection présidentielle
puisqu'il a encore perdu des points dans
les sondages ce week end même s'il reste
encore assez assez haut dans ces
sondages mais on voit bien que il ya
quelque chose là qui pourrait être
dangereux pour la candidature d'emmanuel
france il s'en était dans ses stratégies
du pass vaccinale qui n'a plus rien à
voir avec la réalité de l'épidémie de
covin comme le disait gabriela talent
même si les cas sont nombreux on voit
bien que les explosions
d'hospitalisation ne suivent pas la
courbe en fait des contaminations donc
on peut se réjouir de ce variant au
micron et se dire que comme l'om est ce
que peut être ça y est nous entrons dans
une nouvelle phase de l'épidémie que
nous en voyons le bout ce serait
formidable mais le placent vaccinale
n'aidera en rien si ce n'est à emmerder
un peu plus des millions de français
merci beaucoup alexis poulain on va voir
d'ailleurs le témoignage d'une femme qui
a beaucoup de difficultés parce qu'elle
ne veut pas se faire vacciner elle a
décidé de ne plus payer ses impôts on
verra cela à 8 heures merci alexis